نحن الان نتواجد في مخيم شعفاط شمال شرقيه
القدس المحتله هذا المخيم واحد من عدد من
القرى والبلدات والضواحي والاحياء التابعه
لمحافظه القدسن قد ساد فيها الاضراب
الشامل وايضا للعصيان المدني وذلك تلبيه
لدعوات من القوه الوطنيه والاسلاميه
والحراك الشباب في محافظه القدس وذلك
احتجاجا على جميع الاجراءات العقابيه
وايضا التنكيليه والقمعيه من قبل السلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه وتحديدا على الحواجز
العسكريه
المحيطه بمدينه القدس المحتله المواطنون
منذ ساعات هذا الفجر قد بداوا هذه
الفعاليات باغلاق المحال التجاريه وايضا
اغلاق جميع المداخل الرئيسيه واشعال
اطارات السيارات في هذه المداخل وذلك
تعبيرا من خلال هؤلاء المواطنين والشبان
على غضب الشارع الفلسطيني تجاه هذه
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه القمعيه التي تمارس
من قبل سلطات الاحتلال بحقهم وتحديدا عند
الحواجز العسكري بما في ذلك عمليات القتل
وايضا هدم المنازل في التي شهدتها هذه
المناطق في خلال الاسابيع الماضيه وايضا
وزير الامن الداخلي الاسرائيلي قد صرح
وغرض منذ صباح هذا اليوم بانه اوعز شرطه
الاحتلال بمواصله هذا النشاط الامني في
محافظه القدس وضواحيها وايضا الضرب يد من
حديد على من يخالف القانون الاسرائيلي على
حد تعبيره القوه الوطنيه والاسلاميه ايضا
قد دعت الى الاف العمال بعدم الذهاب الى
ماكينه عملهم في داخل اسرائيل وايضا طلبت
المدارس واغلاق جميع او عدم التعامل مع اي
مؤسسه رسميه من خلال دفع الرسوم والضرائب
وذلك تعبيرا عن غضب الشارع الفلسطيني
اتجاه هذه الاجراءات القمعيه الاسرائيليه
سمير ابو شمال الجزيره من مخيم شعفاط شمال
شرقي القدس المحتله